going back to what you said about
goal-oriented people and referring to
the students that you had initially
talked about
do you think that people are just
naturally goal-oriented
they're just out of the womb that way or
that they can develop that over time
through trial and error and pain and all
of that
i think that we are as a species we are
goal oriented i think it's a natural
thing
and it's something that i think
to a degree
you need to fight against i i think what
where the um
where it can be a problem
it's not so much that these
that people aren't goal oriented as the
goal
is always just over the horizon so it's
this idea of um yeah i'm not doing the
thing i really want to do so i'm not
going to set myself any serious goals at
this point because my serious goal is
that i'll be
working in this career earning this
amount of money with this amount of
recognition at some point in the future
so that's where
then
i'm really going to start picking up the
opportunities i'm really going to apply
my energies to everything
whereas the the truth is um
you have to
you have to set goals earlier than that
you know and you have to buy into them
earlier than that it's no good if all of
my energy is putting some goal that is
happening
two years from now
and i'm not doing anything significant
until that happens i'll never get to
that goal you know i need to i need to
commit to something now i need to
emotionally involve myself in something
now i need to see the opportunity
it can be hard to see opportunities
i actually uh i was given a book as a
present called yes man or something and
it was this
uh guy who promised to say yes to
everything for a year
and uh i was and he and he had lots of
interesting opportunities and i realized
that i was being a yes man in the
positive sense i was saying yes there's
that movie as well wasn't there what do
you recall it jim carrey
yes man was it so
i realized that i was saying yes to a
lot of things um and i realized how
important it was every every project
that would come up i'd say yes to i
wouldn't say
oh
this isn't cool enough or this isn't
exactly what i want to do so i'm going
to say no
and
i think
one of the things that helped me say yes
is i knew
i knew where i wanted to go not the
direction i didn't know precisely what
needed to be done to get there but i
knew this was it i wanted to be an
artist this was it and this is what i
dr divided my salary by 0.33 no that's
multiplied it by 0.33
i lowered my salary by two-thirds i was
in this new situation
i was trying to do art but i was
perceived as a
programmer or a researcher in artificial
intelligence
and i had to say yes i'd say yes to
everything you know if it was if it was
a real
project
that's an interesting element though
that i i hadn't thought about when i
look back at the things i said yes to
they tended to all be projects that
would
almost guaranteed to come to fruition
that's one of the things that's uh and i
think sometimes
maybe that does make a difference maybe
that's one of the reasons i sometimes
found it hard to get people to buy into
a project because they may be bought
into projects before that have not come
to fruition
and these i always do projects if if
i told you i kill off a lot of projects
naturally but if a project gets to the
point where you know i'm talking about a
performance and all that you know then
then um
this project's going to come to fruition
so if you buy into this project there
will be a performance there will be a
showing there will be something look at
what's happened with my past
performances my past showings look at
and i think sometimes people are so used
to being involved in projects that never
really go anywhere or never really
finish or never achieve their potential
that
that that can lower their goal
orientation so they're always thinking
that the real project is somewhere over
the horizon the real satisfaction is
somewhere over the horizon of course i'm
not a psychologist you can probably
guess everything i'm saying is from my
own experience i talk about other people
i'm just extrapolating from my own from
how i've been you know and it all the
most wise words on this the most
convincingly worded words on this are
just the pink floyd song time you know
that that the lyrics i'd say for anyone
that's waiting for that big thing to
happen
listen to the lyrics of the pink floyd
song time if you haven't already because
um
it it puts it in such a simple and yes
effective way and
i heard it for years before i actually
truly
through the pain of sitting at that desk
knowing i didn't want to be there
actually started to use the time that i
had
you